often the CV review interview is rather
done in the beginning and one of the
earlier maybe even the first interview
it is supposed to break the eyes a bit
because of course as a candidate It is
believed that you can easily talk about
yourself that this puts you in less
stress than for instance doing a more
complicated case study so just ease up a
bit be ready to build some rapport with
your interviewer get to know each other
and just try to have a good time however
how some firms do use the CV review
section is to drill down a bit to Deep
dive a bit on some of the things that
you write in your CV and might
especially do that if they have some
reason to maybe doubt whether some
things that your right are really
accurate or not you're ready to go into
some level of detail to really give the
interviewer the comfort that of course
everything that you wrote is completely
accurate and completely correct